tous les studios de canal factory ont
soudainement cessé de fonctionner en
milieu d'après midi ça s'est passé aux
alentours de 15h branle-bas-de-combat
bacchanales factory les gens m'appellent
syrie non on a un souci technique
pour l'instant rien ne marche ma
première question va-t-on pouvoir faire
le 6 à 7
ou même le 6 à
[Rires]
6,6 à 6 ans fument
les gens me répondent non les gens me
disent on va prendre du navire est ce
qu'on appelle une petite caméra comme ça
voilà pour les films et déjà pour le 6 à
7 ça suffira
c'est ce que m'a dit le patron de ses
vitres francs capitaux merci les équipes
de lakanal factory ont travaillé toute
la nuit pour essayer de comprendre d'où
venait le problème
est à 5 heures du matin ils se sont
rendus compte
qu'ils avaient oublié de mettre des
piles
énormément de spéculation 1 sur la
raison de ces gros soucis techniques qui
sont arrivés au même moment et certaines
personnes disent même que cela pourrait
être les conséquences d'une cyberattaque
ce qu'on a dit hier sur la cyber attaque
a eu des conséquences au niveau national
je vous jure que c'est vrai oui je vous
en parlais d'horribles c'est bon je vous
en parlais dans un instant vous allez
voir on a même été contactés par le
gouvernement je ne rigole par noro qui
s'est inquiété pour nous non pas vous y
en a [ __ ]
je vous le dit c'est vrai vous allez
voir c'est passé regardez ce qui s'est
passé hier on vous donnera les vraies
raisons dans un instant et on dort avec
nous ils rice expert en cybersécurité
giron de primes lint.com qui va nous
dire ce qui peut se passer et si sur
spotify sur france 24 il y a eu bien
entendu des cyber attaques on va en
parler juste après 4,6 à avoir et ça
c'est un gros dossier râle je sais que
vous avez peur pour moi ce quoi et ça
pour moi c'est leur attaque qu'est ce
que tu as pour moi cette cyber attaque
comprends pas ce que tu dis pour moi
c'est une cyber attaque sa valeur
vous dire dans un instant ce qui s'est
réellement passé vous allez voir ça va
faire froid dans le dos et vous des
morts serait peut-être l'occasion
également de
il est 18 ans 11 contre les équipes de
touche pas à mon poste et du 6 et 7
s'apprête à prendre l'antenne mais la
régie de canal+ est confronté à un
énorme bug technique suit un point
technique nous ne pouvons pas prendre le
direct dans le 6 à 7 pts 2 excuses on se
retrouve dans un instant avec cyril
hanouna pour tpm pays contraint de
lancer une rediffusion pendant plus
d'une heure cyril va finalement tenté de
prendre l'antenne à 19h22 tout à péter
sachez que toute l'équipe de ses 8 est
en train de faire le nécessaire certains
bruits de couloir affirme alors que
l'émission serait victime d'une
cyber-attaque micro à la main cyril va
tenter d'assurer le show en vain à 20h17
nous sommes forcés de rendre l'antenne
malheureusement doiron doit stopper
l'émission on est vraiment dégoûté si ce
soit nous sommes de retour en direct
d'autres médias comme spotify netflix ou
wikipedia ont rencontré des problèmes
similaires ces derniers jours ce qui
nous amène à nous poser ces questions
tâche nc 8 at elle vraiment été victime
d'une cyberattaque est le pire est-il à
venir
crise on va revenir avec idris expert en
cybersécurité gérant de près unique.com
irin va nous parler de ce qui se passe
en ukraine ce qui se passe en russie
bien entendu merci idriss il reste très
très forte bonsoir il faut venir il peut
vous cyberattaque est maintenant de loin
comme comme ça
il ya un cyber attaques et isabelle non
il va nous parler de tout ça et il va
nous dire si il est possible qu'on
subisse des cyber attaques parce que
j'ai beaucoup de choses à dire qu'ils
sont passés on a parlé de spotify en a
parlé de france 24 de wikipédia on va
revenir déjà guère depuis le début 15h30
les équipes de lakanal factory remarque
qu'il ya un problème technique au niveau
de la région
17 heures les équipes de lakanal factory
confirme qui dit
qu'il avait un problème au niveau de la
régie les équipes de tpv sont informés à
ce stade il y avait 50% de chances que
l'émission soit annulée parce que les
équipes de canal n'arrivait pas à
trouver d'où venait le problème
18h10 drame dans le paf
le 6 à 7 et adultes
ces 8 continue diffusion d'émissions tpm
peu entêté en attendant que le problème
soit résolu
19h10 on prend l'antenne trop bien que
mal et à cause du signal instable le son
ne fait que couple batteur va au bout
d'une heure d'émission je me décide à
rendre l'antenne de minuit à 4 heures du
matin les ingénieurs de lakanal factory
dean
puis à 4 heures du matin ils ont
commencé à travailler d'arrache-pied
pour tenter de résoudre ce souci pour
remonter la source du problème ils ont
fait de nombreux tests début d'après
midi aujourd'hui
les équipes reviennent
ils goûtent
papy brossard chocobo leurs autres
friandises sigaud lui
et des équipements va trouver la cause
de ce bug technique
en fait
les cartes réseaux sont auraient toutes
les deux trams est donc en fait fallu
changer la carte non c'est comme des
filles l'adorent la seriat ce poids là
oui dans le match vous donner des
explications dans la canal factory un
coeur de réseau
vainqueur de rythme à coeur de réseau
c'est un énorme ordinateur avec des
milliers d'informations et de systèmes
informatiques dans ce coeur de réseau il
ya deux cartes réseaux sont une
originale et une de rechange ces deux
cartes dysfonctionné donc la normale là
est la salle de rechange et la carte
principale envoyer des mauvais signaux à
la carte de remplacement donc en fait
ces dysfonctionnements se sont
répercutées sur le système sont de
toutes las canals factory et voilà donc
est donc ce soir pour anticiper un
potentiel bonne technique les équipes
ont prévu une console sont de secours ma
maison est juste a changé en fait la
carte